[Musique]
véritable hymne à ma chère et tendre il
dans les cités marseillaises qui
viennent y rentrer par là il ya le
guetteur de la bourse de paris sur votre
appui métiers pour tous à vos
commerciaux mais aussi monter un
business reste la débrouille on fait ça
regardez c'était une école maternelle on
est en crise toutes l'année d'un
campement toute l'année depuis toujours
pas si cela continue je t'aime tu peux
parler tous les jours a confirmé au
passé la même c'est juste chez nous on
ne peut pas sortir du quartier en
restant sont encore en jeu contre
orléans ne rapide je vous emmène
aujourd'hui pour brut à marseille dans
une cité du 15e arrondissement
la cité bassens confinement au pas ici
il n'y a pas de famille ce public
quasiment aucun transport et les
habitants sont isolés de tout bassin
c'est un quartier comme il en existe
beaucoup en france
il a été construit dans les années 60
pour reloger des familles algériennes et
gitane qui vivaient dans des bidonvilles
et sept cités prévue pour être
provisoire elle est toujours là 60 ans
plus tard puis de moins en retard de
loyer les maisons ces mêmes ados n'ont
pas eu le droit de me mettre dehors
parce que il ya quand il ment le virus
et la crise économique qui va avec ont
des conséquences très concrètes ici et
vous allez le voir ce sont les femmes de
la cité qui prennent les choses en main
toute la cité fait qu'une seule famille
et c'est ça qui nous qui
on n'est pas une cité très dangereuse
dans une cité très familial on s'aime
tous avec ou sans le confinement
on en crise toute l'année alors qu'en
fumant toute l'année depuis que depuis
toujours c'est cela confirme que j'ai
aussi de pas trop mais que nous avons
expliqué les secours et là on est au
local de l'association des femmes de
bassens sa présente pour vous ce weekend
répète ça représente tout voilà nos vies
nos amis quand on s'ennuie on vient là
par tous les enfants ont des parents qui
peuvent les aider parce que pas tout le
monde de par le tout écrit français
heureusement qu'on a à nadja qui est là
pour nous en parle c'est dans lequel par
exemple et la tête de combien d'enfants
comme s'agisse du collège un prix
jeunesse m kouassi a été lancée après il
ya des primaires je sais pas j'ai menti
ce n'est pas pour demain qu'est ce que
tu penses de cette histoire des
colombiens de débiles confinement et je
suis un exemple d'accès internet et ne
faisant pas d'ordinateur un exemple
imprimant un exemple qui n'ont pas été
touchés j'ai fait une année de droit
après je partais en belgique
j'ai commencé l'école d'infirmières
bigeard était pour m'occuper de mes
parents je vois pas qui est malade ce
qui a handicapé à 38
tout le monde est fier de mes parents et
ces gars là est ce que tu peux expliquer
à quel est ton rôle depuis le
confinement de tous les jours j'aide les
gens à faire des cours des papiers les
amener chez le notaire les emmener
approbation
je fais la bénévole toute la journée
avec les ânes confinement bonjour je
vais récupérer des chèques que et des
kits éducatif lassé des jouets cd chèque
service est utilisé dans les grandes
surfaces pour les produits
d'alimentation et d'hygiène
et qu'est-ce qui se passerait si elle
est assez chèque et que dire des
familles
qui finirait pas à la fin du mois
sachant que nord rentrer bientôt dans le
mois du ramadan
c'est comment l'ambiance à la cense
comment comment nuit
et puis on est une famille qui fait
avorter
c'est une maison et chaque appartement
c'est une chambre d mais on met les
balcons les places et les petits jeux
mac un truc c'est que des femmes qui
s'occupent de ça or et c'est vrai qu'à
voir qui est qui avait les hommes
veulent rien faire tant d accord
j'étudie les femmes dans mon quartier
pourquoi parce qu'on gardait ce ne fut
pas la seule à réussir dans notre
quartier ces gentilles comme il y en a
un de moins de 3000 mètres en amont il
n'y a rien au hasard
j'ai 15 à 17 ans et 13 indique dans un
ghetto et 3 000 séries télé jouer rossi
fut peu près dans la premier set dj tool
et le chéri de repos les chats cela
s'avéra parisy données matin montre
bassesse
je vais vous montrer les appartements
combiné et s'il est là c'est la
boulangerie vous connaissez me du cac
qui travaillait dans chaque équipe il
sacré dragon quest la nationa d'autres
non si la palud on n'a rien à envier
on n'a pas de centre aéré pas d'activité
encore ça va il est entretenu et
celui-là
ils sont tous entraînés à part le
bâtiment où j'habite mans voilà la
célèbre série gta décor que les poules
c'est la cité basse et c'est normal
attention madame le temps d'être à moi
j'habite ici bas tu manges et capable de
gérer ces risques
c'est mon fils bonjour les escaliers
c'est ce qu'a dit la plus kitsch
territoire est maintenant si c'est voir
comment je vis ça fait tellement regardé
la part comment allait sa fait et non
apple voit ta mère est là c'est pour les
tickets restaurant près inconnu ça fait
un an et demi frère qu'elle est comme ça
m'apporte devant la presse deux hommes
s'étaient vus physique surtout sur celle
par force qui sait rester bloqué comme
athée est resté coincé à l'intérieur et
que l'on est obligé de m écouter pour la
casse et électricité qui sortent seuls
c'est plus que j'ai parlé aussi monsieur
qui est en train de prendre feu à cause
des cafards qui avait enfin c'est son
jeu préféré forte lie tous les enfants
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ne font qu'un
j'ai eu deux mois en retard de loyer
l'humérus et me met dehors c'est enfin
l'agent pas eu le droit de me mettre
dehors parce qu'il ya un confinement bon
match très sage paye le loyer
l'électricité la chine l'assurance non
vie avec un appartement dans cet
immeuble hlm c'est 400 euros par mois
abbas ans les habitants l'impression
d'être les citoyens de seconde zone
et quand le travail manque c'est la
débrouille qui s'imposent et pour
certains ça passe par les petits trafics
les couleurs ils viennent ils rentrent
par là les accès des dahlias le guetteur
devant contout qui la pousse à rentrer à
pied il écrit que sa lumière sur le mur
et a écrit bassens nom du quartier
il a écrit la direction de sud rail il
ya le menu les morceaux à gc du bord en
jaune les morts 130 aussi les morceaux
assez content d'amou la 307 la bonne
fumant
et en fait vous ne cachez pas du tout
pour le faire vous cachez pas du tout
pour le faire commence à se cacher elle
invite tout le monde
des convois des personnes âgées en cas
ça par respect mais après les habitantes
cité droit vécu il son droit avec toi
c'est un bon quartier ce quartier du
fils de [ __ ] si l'huile est comme ça ce
n'est qu'un cube mois table à jeux
combats de mains sur la séance à ce
cadeau sous ces 90 10 légal est ce que
tu peux me dire à quel âge tu as et quel
est ton parcours depuis combien de temps
tu fais simple je fais ça depuis l'âge
de 12 ans j'ai 16 ans tu travailles
d'erding par semaine avec le confinement
s'est passé de 10h à 21h ça va avancer
de 19h à 1h du matin à partir de 21
heures les gens il sera plus ça veut
dire personne qui vient samedi
renferment plus tôt et pourquoi tu fais
ça c'est de l'argent facile et tu achète
quoi avec ça voilà comment dix ans
coffre on n'achète rien en coffre et tu
es tu ta famille ex bien sûr première
personne à qui est décédée par an les
prêts la famille qui leur donne combien
par mois après environ 1500 le reste il
est pour moi et ils sont au courant de
ce que tu fais
ah ça c'est autre chose on peut dire oui
et non oui il ya des doutes tu vois mais
non ils sont pas sûrs en sept manches
j'étais à l'école je travaille bien on
va dire j'ai fréquenté une mauvaise
personne par exemple les week-ends je
faisais ça il la semaine je partais à
l'école américaine the march of dimes
petit truc tu vois je comprends pas et
là pendant deux mois de confinement va
là j'ai saigné c'est moi de continuer et
j'ai bien coffret un petit peu c'est bon
et cette manip à l'école l'école
franchement ouais ça manque l'école les
collègues est tombé après que sa mère ou
là vous allez faire l'été la maquette
est apparue justement de tout à de finir
en prison
franchement je vais pas vous mentir maj
pas peur parce qu'on peut le dire à pire
que la prison des représailles des
règlements de compte ça avait
une fin 2016 est ce que t'as pas
l'impression parfois que peut-être que
tu gâches ta vie peut-être que tu devais
franchement des fois je me dis je
devrais pas faire ça mais après le soir
quand tu reçois taper tu es tranquille
tu es calais faut juste être intelligent
quand tu fais ça bien réfléchir bien
cacher les affaires savoir conserver le
client contrôle de police terrain
surtout à hitler à décrire le quartier
décrit celui bâtiment si je me trompe
pas de quatre étages je venais chercher
à 312 habitants et un cow boy à des
appartements sont vides
l'industriel a que des usines au tour
des pompiers touchant en au milieu de
nulle part
mapei le cadre d'un soudard je sors de
détention une charge de 58 ans je vis
ici à bassens voilà on n'a pas la vie
facile tous les jours
j'ai fait un film qui s'appelle
sherazade qui est sorti en 2018
réalisé par jean bernard marlins
récompense est trop fort césar du
meilleur acteur et actrice et sport les
meilleurs films de l'année 2018 j'avais
le troisième rôle de sue m'expliquer
comment ça se passe ton confinement ça
sans avoir à le confinement bouge pas
trop hein et là au quartier voilà ne pas
trop bouger qu'une
mais des amendes et une femme aident un
petit peu alors on fait comme on peut
on essaie de survivre est de vivre comme
on dit chez nous chacun savait que ce
avec le moyen glidji mauvais chacun fait
avec les moyens du bord je lui montre un
peu le quartier
c'est dans ce laps de temps le deuxième
type sépulture et charlotte d'études
et c'est quoi ton rêve pour l'avenir moi
je sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là pour mettre mon malaise déjà faut
mettre un moment sécurité après on verra
pour le reste
ça répond pas joué hier à la halle aux
puces le froid ça c'est mon coin de
bonheur
moi je m'appelle guerra j'habite à la
scène ce depuis 20 ans et je suis aide
soignante en réanimation et en ce moment
je suis un plaisir secteur qu vides et
alors comment ça se passe pour vous
cette période de crise comment ça se
passait bien on va retravailler avec la
boule au ventre de jour en jour on a
moins de matériel
malheureusement et c'est comment
l'ambiance à bâle fins et c'est une
cartier fabuleux en fait il faut être né
à bassens pour comprendre la mentalité
bassens et c'est génial en fait c'est
c'est toute une fratrie et là c'est
l'ancienne école maternelle mon école ça
va fermer
l'amiante et du coup ça devenait trop
tôt trop cher de réparer de dons qu'ils
ont laissées à l'abandon
ça c'est bien malheureux parce que y'a
sais pas combien de mètres au carré
on pourrait faire enfin c'était prévu
qu'on passe à une grand jardin pour les
petites mais m et puis du grand jardin
sera pas ça rate mini jardin
[Musique]
on fait comment on peut
en fait les moyens du bord
[Musique]
or des gens qui n'ont plus bas qu'à ça
voilà des autres on nous donne excitée
c'était une école maternelle jugé que
c'était une des écoles api la plus
propre et la plus géniale de marseille
et tti celle écrite
j'étais là l'école louis est en fait ils
ont ils regardent ils ont construit un
pass c'est un commissariat sa bouille
leblanc là bas c'est le plus gros
commencera de marseille ben disons oui
le race to me sens alors comme ça
on est demandeur de fumer bien d'autres
non ça c'est les sens mais 36 et les 30
cm en plus souvent pendant quatre ans
avant moi ça vaut un mois plus tard et
qu'est-ce qui se passerait s'il est
assez petit business ces squelettes
mais c'est bon business c'est rien c'est
la débrouille d'été où il ya quelques
mois la jeter en prison
et alors quand est sorti de prison à
cause du courant grâce aux corners en
prison y avait trop de gens qui va
attraper moi je n'avais pas bien mais
bon laisser sortir tech que content vive
le connaît ses meilleurs quartiers
maîtres comme eu ce quartier c'est
normal de leur quartier s'ils étaient à
refaire est-ce que tu refais les mêmes
la vérité ben non [ __ ] c'est haro
faire je vais travailler à l'école j'ai
géré relever les manches et travailler
s'est offert ses plus brillants passants
regardent ils ont quel avenir que ces
jeunes là qu'est venir lui l'attrait de
80 la mairie dont je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
des coups à taza voilà comment le
confinement le vie si on a besoin d'un
truc ont fait le yo comme en prison le
yoyo iman tu me fait le yo yo pendant
cinq ans
à
tous les soirs il sait tout ça va
m'interdire épisode avait perdu sa
libération
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
12h12 vous blesser
[Applaudissements]
vise à les distribuer des chèques qui me
restait j'ai donné à des familles qui
n'ont pas lu ce matin à mon rythme
[Applaudissements]
m
on peut déceler j'ai un travail dénonce
comme ce cas oui c'est un bonheur la
part de mes collègues la vie de famille
c'est pour montrer qu'on passe à l'acte
m
viviane je taille
[Applaudissements]
là
tél